[Musica]
vicinanza l'essere vicino nello spazio
nel tempo i luoghi vicini ma anche
affinità somiglianza è ancora con una
definizione un po più arcaica il
vicinato
i vicini vicinanza e quindi un concetto
ampio che coinvolge la materia gli
oggetti fisici così come le relazioni
tra le persone tra le famiglie tra le
comunità oggi vi parlerò di cohousing vi
illustrerò di cosa si tratta
anche se molti di voi già lo
conosceranno proponendovi cosa potrebbe
diventare co housing parlerò quindi di
un modello abitativo in cui non è
importante essere vicini solo da un
punto di vista fisico ma soprattutto da
un punto di vista relazionale e vi
parlerò anche del fatto che le strutture
fisiche ossia gli edifici le
architetture devono essere
caratterizzate dalla vicinanza
partirò proprio da questo punto ossia
della vicinanza nello spazio delle
strutture fisiche
una delle caratteristiche principali dei
paesi e delle città post moderne e
quella della dispersione della residenza
così come dei servizi pubblici e privati
periferie sempre più estese aggrediscono
lo spazio rurale mentre grossi propoli
commerciali si dispongono lontani dal
centro sostituendo reti di piccole
attività locali il numero delle degli
edifici inutilizzati e diventa sempre
più alto
nonostante ciò tra alti e bassi la
costruzione di nuove architetture
continua inesorabile a consumare il
suolo
secondo un recente censimento dell'istat
sono ben oltre 260 mila le abitazioni
utilizzate in sardegna circa il 28 per
cento del patrimonio abitativo isolano
in italia sono stimate 7 milioni di
abitazioni vuote per la maggior parte si
tratta di case vacanze sicuramente di
seconde case ma per ben 2,7 milioni di
queste parliamo di abitazioni
inutilizzate e non è un problema solo
italiano dato che in europa una casa su
6 risulta essere in utilizzata risulta
essere vuota
nel mentre il cemento continua mangiare
il suolo
ad un ritmo di quattro metri quadrati al
secondo ma continuiamo ad aggiungere
problemi
continuiamo a raggiungere delle
problematiche
abbiamo appena parlato di quello che il
patrimonio inutilizzato di un degrado
che quindi è di tipo fisico ma
soffermiamoci un attimo un attimo a
pensare a quelle che sono gli spazi in
cui viviamo che quindi hanno una
funzione hanno un uso
ora non so quanti di voi siano abitanti
di vicinato idiliaci dove vige l'amore
tra le persone ognuno si prende cura
della propria casa non crede lo spazio
vicino e delle relazioni
questo non è il mio caso il tuo vicino
che mi ha preparato la cena
probabilmente no in realtà noi
rientriamo all'interno dei nostri
condomini a malapena ci salutiamo al
nostro rientro a casa troviamo la luce
comuni accese anziché parlarne con i
nostri vicini di casa per trovare una
soluzione per ricordarci di spegnerla
appunto da spegniamo con rabbia e
accumuliamo il nostro il rancore
spaziamo lo spazio di fronte a casa
nostra ma non abbiamo problemi a
prendere la busta della spazzatura e
buttarla nel giardino del posto
esagerando scherza forse forse
insomma dunque questi che sono degli
spazi utilizzati degli spazi vissuti
sono veramente migliori di quel
patrimonio utilizzato di cui vi ho
parlato prima
in realtà almeno per quanto mi riguarda
mi sembra di vedere una certa bruttezza
in questo spazio fisico una bruttezza
che sicuramente di tipo tangibile la
spazzatura
la sporcizia esterni poco curati ma è
soprattutto una bruttezza di tipo
relazionale manca lo spirito manca la
voglia di stare assieme
quelle che sono persone che vivono
vicino a noi le teniamo a distanza
rifiutiamo in un certo modo la vicinanza
potrei parlarvi per ore per ora un po
esagerato parlare di di solitudine di
mancanza di relazioni di conflitti di
vicini che si ammazzano per futili
motivi
gli anziani di morti che vengono
ritrovati nella propria abitazione dopo
mesi credo che siate in grado di
comprendere che alla base di queste
problematiche di tipo relazionale
appunto ci siano tra le cause maggiori
dei modelli abitativi che inducono
all'allontanamento all'isolamento
combinati con delle fenomenologie di cui
non staremo a parlare qua basta problemi
dunque che cosa immaginiamo come
soluzione non sta usando un plurale
maiestatis così random ma sono
problematiche che affrontiamo con la
nostra associazione un'associazione che
si occupa dati del tema dunque qual è la
soluzione secondo noi non abbiamo la
pagina panacea per tutti i mali
chiaramente soprattutto per questa
incapacità di riutilizzare i nostri beni
per la conti continuo consumo di suolo
la cina intimi cementificazione dei
fiori per la mancanza di strategie e
programmi di recupero integrato
dell'architettura inutilizzata
non abbiamo una soluzione assoluta ma
abbiamo una proposta trasformare il
patrimonio utilizzato parte del
patrimonio utilizzato in in cohousing ma
che cosa è il co housing
immaginate un vicinato in vecchio stile
un vero vicinato però dove serviva
mancava un uovo o lo zucchero non
avevate il timore di chiederlo al vostro
vicino di casa dove non avevate i
problemi ad affinare il vostro bambino
alla vicina di casa
all'anziana che vive di fianco a voi
dove lo stesso bambino poteva fare
compagnia a questa signora anziana che
magari viveva da sola qual è la
differenza fra questa idea di vicinato
per così dire tradizionale e il co
housing
la differenza sta nel intenzionalità
infatti per la realizzazione di un co
housing un gruppo di persone si sceglie
crea il cosiddetto avvicinato elettivo e
realizza il proprio cohousing un luogo o
progettato nel co housing si vive
assieme o progettate in quanto tutti
assieme si decide
quali come come progettare il nostro
spazio privato i nostri spazi privati
nonché quegli spazi condividere e vivere
assieme e co gestire in altri porti in
altre parole all'interno di un co
housing ciascun nucleo di ciascun nucleo
familiare ha la propria abitazione
il proprio appartamento e al contempo ha
la possibilità di usufruire e di
condividere il sembra su pc l'aperitivo
gli spazi aggiuntivi una sala lettura
una seconda cucina più ampia una sala
multiuso un cortile un'officina
qualsiasi cosa il gruppo abbia
intenzione di realizzare e di
condividere appunto
faccio un esempio pratico faccio un
esempio pratico siamo dieci famiglie di
tipologia mista la coppia di anziani che
vive da sola una famiglia con con
bambini il professionista single altri
sette stereotipi di questo tipo
tutti assieme
costituiamo quello che è il vicinato
elettivo e decidiamo di acquistare una
bella casa campidanese ben ristrutturata
da ristrutturare una capitan ese molto
grande al suo interno non ci non ci
realizziamo un condominio per così dire
semplice e classico come come lo
conosciamo appunto assieme decidiamo
come progettare le nostre dieci
abitazioni e quali spazi condividere ad
esempio ciascuno di noi ciascuna nucleo
familiare decide di rinunciare ad
esempio ad uno studio allo studio che
solitamente c'è nella casa privata o
alla seconda cucina quelle norme che
utilizziamo 2 35 volte in un anno
in totale è piuttosto decidiamo di
dedicare una porzione di questa casa
campidanese ad una sala comune magari
attrezzata di cucina oppure di spazi per
il lavoro possiamo anche decidere di non
utili di non avere una lavatrice a
persona ma piuttosto di dedicare una
parte del nostro co housing a una
attrezzandolo con una o più lavatrici
asciugatrici ed avere quindi una super
lavanderia comune possiamo anche lavare
i panni di tutto avvicinate magari farci
a farci pagare
possiamo inoltre decidere di impiegare
delle tecniche dei materiali che siano
ad alto standard energetico fermo
climatico
qual è il vantaggio di tutto ciò
innanzitutto avremo sicuramente un
vantaggio ambientale
stiamo riutilizzando un edificio stiamo
massimizzando gli spazi e loro utilizzo
stiamo riducendo le emissioni di co2
attraverso l'impiego di attraverso
l'utilizzo di una casa ad alto
efficientamento energetico
avremo inoltre del dei vantaggi
economici
potremo infatti all'interno del nostro
co housing costituire dei gruppi
d'acquisto sia per la costruzione della
casa più materiali compriamo più alta la
probabilità di avere uno sconto sia per
il futuro acquisto di beni di prima
necessità
potremmo razionalizzare gli impianti e
in questo modo massimizzare sia il loro
utilizzo che le spese ad esse connesse
potremmo anche decidere di dedicare una
parte del cohousing ad un'attività
commerciale oppure ad un bed and
breakfast in modo tale da trovare delle
fonti di guadagno alternative questi
sono solo alcuni degli esempi e finora
non abbiamo ancora parlato di quelli che
sono i vantaggi sociali ossia quelli
connessi alle problematiche di
individualizzazione della società e di
disgregamento delle comunità quali sono
i vantaggi sociali in un co housing
noi siamo costretti volontariamente
ovviamente a salutarci perché molto
probabilmente realizzeremo un'area di
accesso comune in cui potremo scambiare
due chiacchiere prima di dirigersi verso
le nostre nido familiare
dovremo per forza confrontarci per poter
decidere come gestire gli spazi e come
mag a ripulire le aree comuni per fare
ciò potremmo anche decidere di
organizzare
una o due cene settimanali in cui
possiamo vederci e prendere appunto
queste decisioni qual è il vantaggio
mi chiederete queste sono tutte
dinamiche che rafforzano la comunità
il nostro vicino aperitivo vederci
parlare condividere un pasto condividere
delle decisioni litigare litigare beh
non penserete che quasi in sia un
paradiso si tratta comunque di un luogo
basato sulle relazioni e queste
relazioni possono essere positive o non
positive parliamo quindi di gestione dei
conflitti
io voglio la cucina televisione nella
sala comune tu invece no tube preparare
la grigliata mista per la cena sociale
io invece sono di vegetariano gestione
dei conflitti e ciò che accade
all'interno di un co housing
noi ci teniamo dentro il nostro mare
essere rancorosi e b rosi ma cerchiamo
di trovare un punto d'incontro
cerchiamo di colmare quelle che sono le
nostre diverse vedute la gestione dei
conflitti non è l'unico aspetto oscuro
del del cohousing per così dire un'altra
sfida importante riguarda la sua
progettazione la sua realizzazione la
sua gestione
immaginate di dover mettere d'accordo
dieci persone su cosa fare come farlo
quando farlo indubbiamente si tratta di
un processo molto lungo e complesso
nonostante ciò chi vive in cohousing
sottolinea che gli aspetti positivi sono
di gran lunga predominanti rispetto agli
aspetti negativi in particolare in
termini di qualità della vita ed i
vantaggi socio culturale per questi
motivi proponiamo e promuoviamo il
modello abitativo del cohousing e lo
proponiamo attraverso il riuso
dell'architettura inutilizzata il
patrimonio inutilizzato
abbiamo parlato di vicinanza nel nello
spazio
parlando di riuso del dell'architettura
per contrastare quelli che sono modelli
abitativi insediativi altamente
dispersivi
abbiamo parlato di vicinanza dal punto
di vista relazionale mettendo in
evidenza che in un vicinato non è
sufficiente essere solamente vicini da
un punto di vista fisico ma che è
necessario che la vicinanza venga
coltivata per concludere infine vorrei
parlare di vicinanza dal punto di vista
del tempo ora noi in queste occasioni
presentiamo e portiamo avanti delle
proposte innovative che possono portare
dei benefici alla società della società
che possono cambiare il mondo
si auspica ma il cohousing davvero un
innovazione soprattutto nel nostro
ambito nell'ambito sardo non solo
lontani i tempi in cui il vicinato era
un punto di riferimento della nostra
struttura sociale
probabilmente subito dopo la famiglia e
al pari delle delle amicizie non sono
lontani i tempi in cui il vicino era un
punto di riferimento per i nostri per un
lavoro che avremmo dovuto fare in casa e
noi avremmo restituito il favore con il
nostro aiuto in un'altra in un altro
momento di un'altra situazione
no in realtà noi non vogliamo innovare
vogliamo piuttosto rinnovare vecchia
architetture con un nuovo significato
una nuova funzione nuove pratiche
abitative che attingono dal dal passato
per un futuro migliore
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]